[Música]
ah
a sus compañeros y amigos con los que en
algún momento hicieron desorden los que
en algún momento profesor le llamó la
atención o simplemente estaban durmiendo
porque no les gustaba la clase yo creo
que acá la basaba en alguna situación o
no se sienten más que identificado en
algún en algún momento
lo curioso de la forma de educar
actualmente es que lleva más de 200 años
en el sistema educativo
lo que me hace reflexionar a partir de
la siguiente frase que dice
albert einstein
así pueden
que menciona que los nuevos métodos
modernos de educativos
no es un milagro se consigue un milagro
que no hayan ahogado las ganas y la
ansia de investigar de ser curioso en
distintos temas
esto
es relevante hoy día en la educación y
es tema fundamental
y lo que ocurre hoy día las clases son
aburridas no existe una motivación por
parte del estudiante
simplemente no tiene una dedicación a la
clase ya que encontramos dos alumnos
típicos el típico alumno que está atento
a lo que dice el profesor atento a lo
que comenta los tips a todo el contexto
de la clase de historia matemática para
los que le gusta la ciencia y tenemos al
alumno que también se aburre el que está
durmiendo el que está con el celular
etcétera
pero esto no se pregunta el por qué
ocurre esto porque hay estudiantes que
no les gusta las clases porque no se
motivan
y lo fundamental y lo que nosotros hemos
cuestionado a estos estudiantes se
refleja en los siguientes comentarios no
sé para qué estudio matemática y en qué
lo voy a aplicar en el futuro porque
estudio de biología y en que lo puedo
aplicar porque tengo que escribir tanto
y no lo aplicó nunca me aburre me da
sueño prefiero dormir estar jugando yo
creo que la mayoría de acá en algún
momento siempre prefirió estar en el
recreo con sus compañeros jugando a la
pelota compartiendo etcétera
esta motivación este cuestionamiento que
hacían los estudiantes desde edades muy
tempranas me motivó a mí a incursionar
en una nueva área en incursionar en las
nuevas formas de educar cómo poder
llegar a que el alumno a los alumnos que
muchas veces son catalogados de
hiperactivos catalogados de que son
flojos y poder llegar a ellos con un
impacto real en el ambiente de la
educación como culmina esto con este
proceso yo inició una investigación en
cómo implementar la robótica en la
educación como a través de la
programación por ejemplo yo puedo
enseñar historia como un chico de 6 años
puede aprender matemáticas a sumar
es bastante interesante no veo yo creo
que aquí más de algunos se ha
cuestionado como gracias a la robótica
un niño puede aprender lenguaje lenguaje
robótica electrónica lo crea imposible
solo en cuestión en algún momento
cuando empezamos a desarrollar distintos
procesos distintos cursos a investigar
con los alumnos pasó algo bastante
interesante donde destacaron
principalmente tres principios
fundamentales el desarrollo humano el
desarrollo personal del estudiante como
el estudiante puede trabajar con sus
compañeros sin tener el prejuicio de mi
compañero me cae mal
no quiero trabajar con él
o romper en tener el típico problema de
de creer que no son capaces de hacer
algún proyecto o alguna idea
qué es lo que pasó verdad de estas
clases el estudiante experimentó una
experiencia significativa en la
educación intrínsecamente aprendió
distintas formas de aprender no las
materias más aburridas para él
qué
quien relacionaba la robótica con la
física con el lenguaje recalcó
nuevamente esta materia
porque todas estas áreas que nosotros
educamos que nosotros estamos enseñando
lo hacían de forma divertida entendían
cómo poder aplicar las distintas áreas
del conocimiento hacia las converger en
proyectos y con la robótica
recuerdo el año pasado el 2017 regreso a
mi colegio donde llegué empecé a hacer
clases de robótica con la sola
motivación de ser un aporte a la forma
de educar actualmente que ocurrió el
primer día de clases afuera de la sala
de robótica tenías más de 100
estudiantes de quinto a octavo básico sí
imagínate estar con 100 estudiantes
haciendo en una clase una locura
pero motivante porque motiva siempre
contarán porque me motiva a mí el hacer
clases para todos de robótica
porque los más pequeños partiendo con
los pequeños de 5º los de octavo séptimo
etcétera
tienen hambre de conocimiento quieren
conocer más
quieren explorar
la sola motivación de decirles robótica
por ejemplo llevar a ellos significan
una motivación importante
a lo largo del año que hicimos el
proyecto el taller de robótica pasaron
bastantes hitos y historias interesantes
fueron momentos anecdóticos momentos de
frustración para muchos
y en particular una historia que a mí me
marcó bastante
qué es la historia del seva
el seva era un chico de 12 años que
cursaba séptimo básico
y va a todas las clases
pero todas era sagrado para él la clase
de robótica porque podía aprender porque
solucionará sus dudas sus
cuestionamientos y siempre siempre
después de las clases me preguntaba
algún concepto que no entendió me decía
profe quiero hacer esto pero no me
encuentro capaz no sé cómo hacerlo no me
atrevo a experimentar
a lo que yo respondí a que tiene que
intentarlo
si falla es parte del proceso
que simplemente tiene que investigar
animarse tener la motivación de
desarrollar la idea paso el tiempo
y él se va seguía siendo el niño tímido
en las clases ponía atención pero no
participaba escribía todo era cosa de
ver su cuaderno o su hoja de apuntes y
tenía todo escrito con dibujos circuitos
que el programación etcétera era
bastante interesante
al finalizar el taller en el colegio
él se ha motivado con una sonrisa doria
es pareja va y me dice profe gracias a
su taller aprendí a trabajar en equipo
gracias a su taller aprendí a enojarme
si fallo
dentro de las experiencias que tuvimos
como no sé cuánto les quemamos ampolleta
hicimos mucho experimento pero adquirir
significaron una experiencia y portal
gracias a su taller me mencionaba subir
mis notas matemáticas son tome mis notas
en matemáticas son hitos importantes
para la edad que significan bastante él
me comentaba al inicio que le costaba
ese material no le gustaba mucho pero
gracias al taller relacionaba la suma
uno más uno a una resistencia un
circuito entonces se generó una
experiencia bastante importante a través
de esto
pero sin embargo
lo que más me impactó lo que más me
llenó fue cuando conocí a sus papás
con sus papás un día en el colegio se me
acerca y me pregunta usted es profesor
de robótica a lo que yo contesto si yo
soy en que lo puedo ayudar
me dice textual
gracias a su taller le cambió la vida a
mi hijo
como un simple taller como
algo tan pequeño un aporte al sistema a
la forma de educar pueden generar tal
impacto el impacto fue en el estudiante
fue la gran organiza al analizar luego
las palabras de la familia
el impacto fue la familia se generó un
impacto importante el chico logró
ampliar su horizonte ya estaba más
motivado en las clases cambió su
personalidad estaba mucho más activo
con solo 12 años
es impactante fue esa situación la que a
mí me motiva
a tomar la decisión concreta ya más de
educar con la robótica decidir educar
porque buscar e impactar en las vidas
educar es cambiar situaciones reales
médicas de todas las personas educar es
pagar a mí me motiva bastante es
satisfactorio ver lo que tú puedes
generar y lo que tú puedes lograr con
simples hechos con simples actos
quizás dentro del público podamos
encontrar próximamente
a la proxima sofía la proxima
investigadora que viaje a eeuu por un
programa científico quizás podamos
encontrar
a cristo feliz y tomás que quisieron
cambiar la vida de los niños a partir de
sus prótesis
o simplemente educar y aprender de forma
entretenida didáctica como los alumnos
que ven en la siguiente fotografía de
una forma entretenida que mejor que
aprender jugando a todo yo creo que les
gusta jugar y divertirse una y si logran
aprender a partir de eso
por eso la motivación que nosotros
tenemos que yo tengo en este momento es
ser un apoyo fundamental un pilar
importante en todas las formas de educar
y llevar la educación yo les pregunto a
ustedes qué esperan de ustedes para
programar el futuro muchas gracias
[Música]